yeah it was uh it's different than usual
so usually I finish everybody in the
first few rounds yeah you know um and
this or you get knocked out or I die
yeah
only when you show up though
[Music]
welcome back to an essential episode of
careful boys today we officially welcome
back the Champs
[Music]
[Applause]
well now he's back after winning this
one's heavy boy which one is your newest
one it's gorgeous he defended this one I
defended that one yeah wow this one's
thick hey when you defend it and you
lose they take the belt away from you
yeah you're supposed to be able to keep
it but promotion sometimes they take it
you can like have one made though right
to like remember your win kind of [__]
yeah so I'm supposed to get another one
for my first defense oh and then I was
like hey can I Rush orders like how much
is one and they're like our cost is 800
I was like dang it I'm like 100 bucks
wow it's so heavy I'm like I need the
numbers you should yeah yeah no that's
for the Memories do you does your lady
ask you to wear and Bone her with it
I
was disrespectful to your sport no no no
okay it's [__] heavy bro you gotta
throw over your shoulder like the
Intercontinental Champion wow
hey no bullets going through my dick
right here bro hey you gotta throw one
up like this dude like the [__] yeah
you gotta go like Stone Cold yeah yeah
yeah yeah back to the stunner post
stunner that's such a good looking belt
they did a really good job yeah this is
my favorite is that your favorite
designing it I I love that one yeah very
very pretty that one's the most like
memorable because everybody recognizes
it oh yeah that was internationally
known the wow is that the first one you
got out of the three uh no that's the
first one I got back in 2000 is it
because WBC is more recognized in wck
yeah so WBC is the largest uh boxing
kickboxing organization yeah but this
doesn't have fur yeah this one this one
feels like a Mongolian wrestlers that
one collabed with like Ugg it's like the
Ugg liner yeah
not fun for the summer this is [__]
Jaguar dude what's that one uh the ifs
so it was uh it was uh I became their
first uh champion of the promotion they
started they called me the Knott's Berry
Farm champion because I fought in
Knott's Berry Farm
we're in knots
[Laughter]
love it dude so tell us about the fight
dude like how many rounds how did you
guys how did you win like okay uh yeah
it was uh it's different than usual so
usually I finish everybody in the first
few rounds yeah you know um and this or
you get knocked out or I die yeah
only when you show up though
Drake yeah
Ron's my Muay Thai coach yeah and then
uh I went out to one of his MMA fights
and he was beating the [__] out of
someone yeah right it was like me David
my boxing coaches their PJ and then
um Ron was like like hunt like uh
stalking him down because you could see
that he was like all hurt and then that
guy just [__] threw like one of those
like Make-a-Wish foundations to make a
wish and then he's like I hope this
works
clean John Cena comes out it's Ron so
clean and you see Ron go down and I
almost felt my [__] entrails come out
of my mouth
is a good one
good one oh yeah he was stalking him
like he was and then he knocked him out
I was supposed to win like without
question so now I don't go to I don't go
to any Ron's fights anymore
yeah so his favorite teams the Rams his
team's been the Rams since the 70s right
yeah he gets so superstitious about how
he's bad luck for the team like he's
such a health uh self-hating
um Filipino man that he would during the
Super Bowl when they're in the Super
Bowl just took a couple years ago he
went outside while everyone's inside he
threw a party he had cooked food made
everything he's like outside drinking a
beer and like [__] like
he won't let himself watch the game
because he's so short he's bad luck oh
my God like he's gonna transfer his bad
luck through the TV you just don't know
you don't know so that's but if he's
away from the TV then it's okay then
they can Ball Out imagine the team shows
up to his house hey mother effort did
you watch did you look over him yeah you
lost it first dick that's how intensely
he treats it
so I love how important he feels yeah
you didn't have any superstitions at all
about your fights
um no I don't really do that because
there's a there's always a new reason
why you lose yeah you know and then you
know you try to you try you try your
best to make sure to never make that
mistake again yeah um for me you know
the old school's like you know make work
your luck so you work more the lucky you
get all that type of stuff and this one
was kickboxing right yeah kickboxing
Muay Thai yeah very similar the only
difference is you can elbow and knee him
a lot so what does this do for your
career is this like this gets you
another shot at something else like how
does all that [__] Works he gets to
promote his towing company yeah wck
Towing now that's a new one
um well they're they're different
organizations kind of like the NFL and
then there's like other leagues right
besides I don't know football whatever
XFL XFL yeah bikini football yeah yeah
so all that stuff so these are different
organizations there's WBC wck
um WBC is the internationally recognized
so as far as WBC is concerned I'm number
one in the US
and then as far as wck isn't uh
concerned I'm number one in the world
whoa but is there is there number one
for your weight class or so there's like
five number ones yeah so there's one
number one in each way class so I'm uh
WC champion at 135 for WBC and then um
uh wck world champion uh 140 pounds for
wck do you feel the pressure from that
like the Target on your back a little
bit yep but luckily in America I fought
most of the contenders in America
um so that's why I had to fight the
number one guy in Mexico
um and so but now that I fought the
number one guy in Mexico uh I'm not
really sure what's the next Asia yeah I
mean that's why I want to go I want to
go to Japan how about Europe yeah or
Europe yeah Africa sure keep naming cars
when does Dana White start calling
um hopefully after this okay yay
but um yeah I mean that's my goal since
I was like in high school was to become
a UFC champion but along the way you
know James changed life changes and
stuff like that I uh I ended up uh going
into a gym called timoyama and ended up
taking like a leadership role there so I
got pulled into the business size as
opposed to the fighting side and so uh
my dreams kind of got transferred I
decided to build the gym instead and
then the gym you know ended up becoming
top 50 best gyms in the world for MMA uh
ranked by the UFC and then so we
accomplished that goal but then I never
got to UFC but all my teammates and
friends did but you built so many people
that yes you supported in Maine yeah I
was happy to be able to take part yeah
which has been great so in essence you
went to the UFC multiple times
[Laughter]
Carlos barza which was a former UFC
champion former two-time two right two
times two times
she will jump through the camera right
now
no that's awesome dude Cheeto Vera's
still killing it yep he's a he's a he's
a he's in contention right he's top 10
uh top 10 Alex Perez Alex Perez fought
for the title
um so definitely and then Fernando
Padilla my teammate he just made his
debut and got fighted the night the last
card oh cool he's a tall skinny guy yeah
we landed like six shots in a row
it was sweet are you do you get to go
whoa do you get to do you get to go and
like stand in their corners and [__] I
do but most of the well but back when I
was more active at the gym um everybody
would go and I would hold down the fort
but I did go to a few fights I went to
uh Ian McCall versus Demetrius Johnson
not the Australia one uh when he did the
rematch in Florida yeah
um yeah oh dude yeah remember that for
those days yeah
um so I got to do that but I didn't do
much I just kind of like just stood
around I rented a car drove around
Eastern Jamaican food
um I felt like I was working I was like
everybody doing good everybody's okay
okay cool I'm gonna I'm gonna eat some
Jamaican jerk chicken so take us take us
through the actual fight man like was it
um did you have nerves going in yeah do
you have confidence the whole way like
every yeah second of it yeah I mean I've
been doing it long enough where uh I
don't really go through the roller
coaster emotions I have complete
confidence in my team the the training
and everything like that those are
actually trained this time because I
know some of the fights you do no no
because sometimes you'll be literally
like like part-time train I'm like Ron
dude come on you're fighting someone
serious but like I'm like I'm trying not
to go to your fight
don't make me go yeah the more I'm gonna
go but like what does part-time training
mean to you like yeah so before when I
was training full time when I was like
at the gym full time and stuff like that
I would train like three times a day I
would do morning training um I would do
strength conditioning or running in the
middle and then I do our night training
you know but these days I got like a kid
and job and bills and stuff like that
crazy bills
freaking life Range Rover bills but keep
going
this guy's good he watches Graham stuff
and yeah
um these days I'm training in the gym
four days a week I do
one training session a day I run every
day and then I do my own gym work so
actual gym time I'm only doing four days
a week uh but it's all I can invest but
I've been banking a lot on my previous
experience and then just trying to
listen to my coaches as best as possible
though when I did that my career
actually got better actually started
getting bigger fights and then winning
more stuff so kind of weird I cut my
training in half and then I produced
twice as much because you work smarter
now yeah it looks smarter not hotter
yeah yeah and how many other Fighters
out there are serial entrepreneur
Fighters huh yeah
I can't do this stuff but that's because
I'm also not really into the sport so I
don't know that many so we're gonna
insert a clip right here this is Ron
fighting the dude he's just totally
pounding this guy into the corner Nick
The Ref calls it a win was there any
point where that opponent actually
surprised you with anything prior to
that or was it well you saw him pictures
of your leg or is your leg still it
doesn't look as it doesn't look as bad
anymore but look it's all purple
it is like up can you imagine getting
[__] to your [__] late like so it
wasn't a walk in the park the last round
that you guys just watched
Braun like walked them down but then it
was a battle getting to that point right
it would have went to decision it would
have been a split decision it was close
wow yeah he was way tougher way smarter
uh probably trained way more than four
times a week yeah yeah damn dude way way
better all around than but I mean shoot
he's uh two division WBC champion Mexico
like he's he had to be legit but we we
didn't anticipate his fighter IQ he was
smart and his Corners were smart he made
it just if when they air the show
um you're gonna see him make adjustments
every single round so how many rounds
did you guys fight uh five five so in
the first round what was the game plan
the first round was to kind of just keep
my distance because I was actually
taller than somebody for once
um I had like a good two inches on him
freaking crazy
um keep my distance and then make him
make mistakes it changed angles don't
get in exchange with the guy um then it
worked I won that round second round I
won and then third round he found his
momentum he found my range he made an
adjustment oh [__] um I was doing this
thing where I was just hitting and then
I would slip to the left and he freaking
read it and so the next time I slipped
it left left instead of finding a cross
he flew across right over here where my
head was going to be so he knew where my
head was going to be and full power
cross right in my face I just went boom
I was like did you have any like did you
get knocked down I got rocked yeah I
haven't been rocked in a long time he
said to me before the cameras turned on
he goes man he was really tough I got
punched twice in the face
like solid I was like oh shoot I hope it
doesn't hit me like that again like that
could have been a knockout if it was the
third time if he kept on hitting me like
that yeah I probably would have got
dropped three strikes you're out so the
first two rounds you're winning yeah
kind of started taking the foot off the
gas a little bit I just kept on doing
the same thing I was like cool we got
this we got this and we didn't we got
comfortable and then he adjusts he's
like in his Corner tell them
time is head movement he's gonna slip to
the left yeah but how often are when you
fight guys it's telegraphing my friends
do they even do they even make those
adjustments they're very rare right this
is my first time that's a good Corner
then yeah it was a very good Corner does
that mean that you've been fighting
impulsive Fighters this whole time I
just been fortunate that I've been
overwhelming most of my opponents oh
from your just yeah just from high
pressure yeah yeah um they haven't had a
chance to really Implement their game
now like all my all the guys I thought
are really good if I would have not
finished it early it would have been
rough like when I fought Travis Clay
like he's freaking good he's like six
one long and freaking if I would have
stayed at his range I would have got
destroyed
um it's like that it's just that small
little change between like dying and not
dying
um yeah I he hit me and I was like Ah
that's a fluke I remember I always think
things are flukes when I get hit and
then I learned my lesson the second time
yeah well I learned about less than a
second time because he did it again in
the fight I moved my head to the left he
threw a cross diagonally boom again and
I got rocked says oh shoot man and then
I had an epiphany I was like this mother
F was reading my head movement I was
like oh so even in your head you don't
cuss
ing guys squiggly Wiggly is [__]
radio
wiggly wiggly
so I was like oh heck no the round ended
and then I told my Corners like hey he's
freaking reading my head moves I get
yeah we know we're gonna do the same
head movement I was like okay oh that's
all I have to do okay all right yeah
don't yell at me I stopped I stopped
slipping and I started rolling and then
sure enough I hit I rolled huge cross
wow bounced off of my roll I was like
and then we're back at it and then you
know fourth round
um I I had the so he won you would say
he won the third maybe uh yeah third and
then the fourth one was very very close
and then the fifth one um he started
picking it up and uh he was just low
kicking the crappiness what was most of
that from the fifth round uh all the fun
he kicked me off the phone oh [__] dude
my leg was black this is like nothing
this is like way better when did you
start feeling did you feel like it took
an effect like what round did you start
feeling in effect from the low kicks oh
not until like later that night until
after that yeah
quit the first time
charlie horses and fighting
um damn that's [__] crazy what turned
it for you on the fifth round look
really you think so I mean I mean it's
you can never really like force a
knockout it kind of just happens yeah so
uh my corner was like hey change up your
pace you're fighting one speed I'm like
Okay cool so I have thoughts I hit slow
I hit slow we're moving we're moving out
of nowhere I I picked up the speed and
did like a super fast jab cross hook and
when I threw it every punch land I was
like so maybe he wasn't
you're he wasn't ready for the the
change the Rhythm dude yep so I just hit
hit bang and then freaking all of them
caught I was like oh and then I felt my
knuckle touch his skull like it went
through my My Gauze
and then like yeah like I I felt his
cheekbone his eyebrows I felt it and
like it just went and if you look at the
fight slipper that's a good connect yeah
his face just ripples oh
are you one of those fight talkers like
like that's right [__] no or your dick
just harder
which one is it I have to wear a cup
that actually like curves to the left
leg it's in the shape of a boner yeah
it's in the shape of one of one of those
squashes with a long curved tip
well I don't feel it
it's outlined if you land one of those
if I are you a talker because I know
some Fighters are like little they talk
to each other I'm not I did it once in
high school before I ever trained I
gotten like a well like my second street
fight ever uh in high school and I saw
some guy beating up my best friend at
the time I was still my best friend now
I was just looking around like you know
at a house party I was just drinking my
Coors Light and then I was like
okay someone's getting Mark get off my
mindset and so I go and pull this guy
off still so nice yeah get off my friend
because I I noticed his Sony Ericsson
phone oh no high school like he got that
you were like bawling that's a big deal
yeah and I was like hey that looks like
and I look mark uh I pull him off and
the guy hits me and I started hitting
him and I go yeah you
yeah
me to my friend I don't think so not
today mister why was he even attacking
him I don't know I just know someone who
was a
bit you wanted the phone yeah
house party kids that are you know I was
a little douchebag too and then the guy
turns around he stops he looks at me and
I look at him and I go
I go Justin
and then he goes wrong yeah we're
friends what the [__] and I was like oh
crap I'm sorry I didn't know it's you
mad because I didn't know it's you
either we hugged each other uh so your
friend was beating up another friend
yeah yeah
but they weren't friends oh weird yeah
so they were cool and then back then you
used helicopters to break break up House
parties
um and so and now that when we're older
like dude you know how much it costs for
a helicopter to break up a house party
or something dude there's probably like
four dollars invested in this whole
party and you're gonna send out a
helicopter you know that'd be funny if
you and that friend started teaming up
on the first guy yeah
mark
you want to steal his phone were you
fighting in Mexico no
um we were fighting at the sycorn casino
in El Cajon
um it's like on the Indian Reservation
super nice Casino it was awesome they
have like a lazy river like a gay club
yeah so that last round that I saw was
that round six uh that was around five
but uh that wasn't the beginning of the
round that was after his 10 count so
after I already dropped them off yeah
they dropped them yeah so that's why
everybody thought it was like the
beginning of round no that was after
they got up oh that makes you okay yeah
so you dropped them with what uh jump in
the jab cross hook so yeah yeah so I'm
just moving moving them all of it landed
he freaking corrupt wow and like he was
stumbling everywhere he held himself up
on the ropes like blatantly I'm not even
exaggerating you're gonna you guys gonna
see the video and I thought they're
going to stop it I was like cool it's
over and then he goes no no I was like
oh snap and I'm over there like this
motherfers and Aztec warrior I'm like
heck yeah wow and they let it go I'm
like okay here we go then that's when I
go in and just yeah but if you look he's
still fighting back he threw like a
roundhouse I have like a bruise on my
ribs
um even with him being out on his feet
like he's still Spirit man yeah dude he
seemed like a good sport like he seemed
like a cool guy he's a martial artist
yeah for sure nothing but respect for
him in his Camp yeah yeah yeah like when
they were like they're lifting your hand
you seemed like really like there's a
cool guy what was it like to fight
someone that gave you that type of
competition for the first time when
you're like oh this guy was an
intelligent fighter this is something
different was it was it scary or was it
like does that raise your confidence it
made me it reminded me why I love Muay
Thai and why why I like to fight like
this level because I'm not this way I'm
37 years old you know I don't know how
much longer I have left I'll keep not
very long probably yeah I'm almost dead
um
um I'm just trying to do whatever I can
and um you know as as long as I can do
it I mean so far it doesn't look like
I'm stopping because
um I'm still doing yeah you're picking
the momentum dude yeah I'll say I'll say
I'm doing you're getting better yeah
yeah so it'll be like cold cop dude be a
senator have you thought about because
you know getting making noise makes
waves right have you thought about like
you know instead of what you just said
he's a martial artist and said you
grabbed the mic and you're like that guy
was a [__] bring on a real guy bring on
a real man I could but it's not my style
what have you did in the wrong way like
saying it lacks like that too I just I
just don't think they're all around that
great of a guy and like I would really
live the opportunity to just ruin your
dreams there you go I want to break your
face it's a Mormon Trash Talk have you
thought of getting his car towed during
the fight you imagine a second I think
it happened only if I lost he's hooked
up already it's like no I won
that's not even his car that's my
promoter's car was your wife at the
fight yeah yeah I mean you can always
hear her oh yeah oh yeah she's like
every time you're getting kicked in late
she's like screaming like yeah it's I
usually never hear her but it got really
quiet at some point and I just hear I
hear her voice to sing and she goes
executive I'm like oh my God
who says that I'm like oh my God bring
up the guillotine yeah I'm just like
paralyzed and I just look I'm just like
is your son there or no no this one was
21 and over so yeah and he's like
[Laughter]
thank you
congratulations
and on additional good news The Reef
will be opening up very soon this month
tentatively yes we have a neon sign
being built for the other side very very
good hey I've been seeing the updates
man it looks like a magical aquarium it
looks so cool I'm I'm literally
um I'm working on getting schools that
go on a school bus and having them drive
and bringing them to the fish store
and then we'll have somebody wear like a
fish hat and look like a Fisher yeah
like this is a fish this is not a fish
do you see the difference
[Laughter]
no